所以以前有个吸毒仔
那个他妈跟他说
我觉得你这样吸毒不好
你要不要认真学点
不然你学点做交易好了
然后他就认真去学当冲
当冲到一半之后他妈又跟他讲
不然你回去吸好了
欢迎收看财经敲能力
我是沁翔
各位观众朋友注意到吗
在2024年年底的时候
立院就通过了一个
你为了你是投资人
还蛮重要的一个法案
就是在2025年开始
要延长三年的这个当充证交税
也就是说一般的交易的证交税呢
大概是千分之三
但是这个当充的证交税
则是千分之1.5
所以让很多当充客
真的是很喜欢做当充电的事情
但是如果你真的是用时间
每天都在盯着盘的时候
做当充真的是可以让你一天
赚了好几十万都说不定
那到底要怎么当充呢
其实盘前盘中跟盘后
都有很多事情要做
今天就來 一起來了解一下這個
我們台灣最大的這個當從客
可以這樣講嗎 全真小哥
沒有到最大的當從客
就是你在檯面上有
你在 你看得到的
我大概算量算很大啦
是不是最大我不確定
至少前三名啦
前三名的
對 至少前三名
但是檯面下有很多做的比我大
台面下 但是他們沒有出來而已
是是是
這時候下面就會有人說
為什麼你還要出來
為什麼要出來喔
不然人生就只有當沖不是很無聊
我也要出來外面
透透氣
透透氣 交交朋友
這完全沒有錯
今天我們錄影的時間是下午
因為他說他早上都要交易
對啊 他說因為我早上
誰跟你早上來錄影
其實當沖還蠻多優點跟缺點
你真的很迷人是不是
我早上來國家稅收少20萬
你說如果早上
那我今天真的是對得起國家
約你下午來
沒錯啊
任何約我早上來
你說那你要拿20萬交易稅捐給國家
所以你每一天的證交稅就20萬
大概20萬
平均
平均20萬
因為一年的交易稅算起來大概四五千萬
那一年算200多個交易日
所以大概就一天大概20萬
所以我們先講一下
為什麼當沖對你來說這麼迷人
它也是有些優點的對不對
當沖就是當天就結算了
所以就是那種反應
那種回饋很直接啊
那種多巴胺非常多
是
那通常你會選擇什麼樣的個股
或者是你會用什麼樣的條件
來做你當沖的選擇
其實當沖
這個我們講了很多啦
可是很多人當沖都憑感覺啦
所以我 第一個喔 你當充憑感覺的 不要充了啦
你充不贏啦
你充不贏啦 我們是專業的 我們不是憑感覺啦
我們是靠程式算籌碼
算連內次連內量 連外次連外量
那我們還可以
不只算籌碼 我們還可以去看籌碼
看當下籌碼 因為這個證交所他還有公布
購買中心他沒有公布
所以当初我们有很多东西可以看
是
所以当你不知道要去看这些东西
一直凭感觉下单的时候
你们家有金山银山都输不完的啦
都输不完的
对啊 你有没有听过一个笑话
什么
所以以前有个吸毒仔
那个他妈跟他说
我觉得你这样吸毒不好
你要不要认真学点
不然你学点做交易好了
然後我就認真去學當沖
當沖到一半之後 他媽又跟他講
不然你回去吸好了
賠光了
賠更多你知道嗎 賠比吸的還得更多
所以意思就說什麼
意思 不要這個
沒學當沖不要來碰啦
不要來碰 因為
你沒有研讀籌碼 你不要來碰當沖啦
不要來碰當沖
因為這個你
你沒學籌碼 老是憑感覺
就快要漲了 繼續買
快要跌了 繼續賣
那個都沒有用
而且台灣大部分人做當中
都是先買再賣
但是據統計啊
做量化交易統計裡面
做先賣再買的勝率是比較高的
所以一般人做當中 一開始就做錯
大部分都是做先買再賣
先買再賣可不可以當中 當然可以啊
先買再賣是適合誰做啊
適合資金很多的人做
像你一樣
可是我也不喜歡做千買再賣
因為千買再賣有一個問題就是
你買了也不曉得誰要把你賣下來
可能就比較麻煩了
所以我們講一下這個當充的優點
一槓桿開很大利用市場不容易獲利
第二個計算籌碼勝率頗高
第三
快速獲取利潤避免隔夜的風險
所以就是一天 今日是今日比
對 第四
可控風險 運用出價單
可以控制當天虧損的最大值
什麼叫出價單
出價單就是價格到了 他要幫你送
所以你會有一個目標
對 例如說
那個 你50塊買了
我說50塊買了 你就要開始放出價單
你要多少錢停損啊
你可以50塊買了嘛 那你就48.9停損
就跌破49塊幫我停損
他就自動幫你賣掉
對 還要掉到48.9 他就自動幫你出掉
就這樣 這叫出價單
好 那這個
第五個 限五當中交易稅減半喔
第六呢 萬一下錯單可以馬上停損
所以當充有這些優點啦
那可以降低虧損部位的成本啦
那這個 例如說空單虧損 流倉盤充即殺
我們就先買
所以這個
你會做當衝
它其實可以幫助你做一些
這個部位的一些調控
是 那它還有一些缺點吧
不然吸毒仔他怎麼會
想要回去吸毒呢
好 我先講當衝缺點一齁
第一個不能留傷即便也是對的
有些人呢 他
他多單啊 他沒有辦法留傷
結果漲停他沒辦法留
所以他就是all in了嘛
所以他必須要除掉
漲停沒辦法留 很可惜耶
對 因為通常漲停隔天容易開高
所以我們都說 當沖
玩當沖的你要有一筆週轉金
要有多少錢
越多越好
對 越多越好
那你資金少的沒關係 你就玩比較小的
那最好就是
最好是你今天這個
你下單量
通常我們都建議說你可能一天下五檔
那每天至少要有一檔你可以留倉的
嗯
對 流上的執行大概是五分之一啦
嗯 好 第二呢 做多跌停所使 沒錢交割
這更慘喔 這有可能會
這好像違約交割
對啊 已經違約了
對啊 那個做多漲停的
很多人都想說賣掉就好了嘛
但是他賣掉也不對啦 因為
他有可能隔天會開高嘛
那做多跌停喔 這個
這個你講沒錢交割 就違約交割
所以這個
這種你可能要去辦個T加5啦
好那第三呢做工漲停鎖死沒錢交割哇哇 這是最慘好 因為漲停鎖死 沒錢交割 又沒券的話
那他要收那個借券費啊
是
這種借券費呢 非常的昂貴
好 第五個
需要大量時間跟精力的關注市場
壓力跟情緒負擔頗大
真的喔
對啊
這是我們每天做我們都習慣了
是
已經沒有壓力大的問題了
這還好啦
那還好啦
就是不要嚇太大都不會壓力大
他都覺得心臟要超大顆
才有辦法做當寵欸
對啊 我後來
我有去醫院檢查我心臟
花了兩萬多塊
做最高級的健康檢查
他跟我說
他沒看過一個心臟這麼好的
真的假的
你就完全沒蓋化
所以心臟真的滿大顆的
對啊 就是每天在
在當中這樣好像鍛鍊出來的
好 長期要付超多的交易稅跟手續費
所以交易稅像我一年付四五千萬
那手續費費也付很多
所以就可以參加很多券商的VIP網會
像今年有看到洆湞演唱會就這樣
好 當中是一下單就虧損
為什麼這樣講
因為你一下單你就要負單手續費交易稅
對
所以一下單就虧損
所以你必須要戰勝手續費加交易稅
這樣要多少%才可以呢
一般來講大概一般人是算千分之二啦
千分之二
千分之二 一般人我們算手續費你可以打個三者的話
算千分之二
那手續費沒有三者的 你不要來玩了啦
不要來玩啦
不要跟我說什麼五者六者玩當衝 不要啦
那個人家玩三者玩當衝都會玩得慘了耶
你看五六者來玩
那我問一下喔 如果我要玩當衝的話
我要先預期這張個股它要漲跌幅多少我才可以賺錢
额 预期涨跌多少
对
额 不要有这种预期
可是不是要扣掉这一些
对 为什么说不要有这种预期
因为 其实扣到这些
扣到这些就是千分之二
嗯
所以至少涨跌就要千分之二嘛
那为什么说不要有预期
嗯
因为 当你有预期的时候
你老是会卡在那边
哎 千分之二
我 就是几个Tick嘛
对
我一个Tick能赚
好啦 我一個Tick我都出
你這樣到後面的績效都很爛
因為
賺錢有分
大賺大賠 小賺小賠嘛
然後呢
你很care那一兩個Tick
那麼你很容易遇到的就是小賺
比方說50塊買我50.2就想賣
對 你就care
對
而且50.2賣
你賺一點點 然後分給券商跟政府
三分天下 你幹嘛
幫兩個人打工幹嘛
對不對
所以當中我們最重要的應該是怎麼樣
不是戰勝成本而已啊
我們當中最重要的是
我們要去找到大勝的機會
大家都很想要找到大勝的機會
對啊 找到大勝的機會就說
你今天做完之後賺10幾%
那叫大勝啊
當中賺10幾% 我剛剛一開拍
我們是不是給你看
直接遇到一個跌停的嘛 碰到一個跌停的
那個就10幾%啦
喔
對 你要遇到
你要有機會賺到10幾%的當充
那種當充才過癮嘛
是
對不對 老是去賺 有的人去
之前有的人開課說
哇 我真的 我覺得市場上齁
不會做交易的 不要出來開課好不好
不要這樣害人
我跟你講 市場上有人出來教課怎麼教你知道嗎
第一堂當充課
欸 當充齁 我們先教各位齁
多少錢呢 我們現在算一個Tick算幾%
例如說100塊
下一個Tick 100.5嘛 是0.5%
那 90塊 下一個Tick是90.1
那算起來大概0.1% 大概這樣子
那所以呢 100塊的0.5% 這個Tick比較大
所以呢 各位同學
我們找當沖的一律要找12開頭的
因為那個TIC比較大
曾效耶
要不然你去沖多大電信啊
都100開頭啊
你去沖它啊
你去沖啊
你看怎麼沖
沖不了喔
是
所以當沖重點不是那TIC啊
重點是它的波動啊
波動
你要今天找一個政府很大的股票
去沖才有意義嘛
對
對不對
你看我剛剛給你看那個
今天波動10幾%
嗯
對不對
你假如高點賣掉 低點回補
你不是賺10幾%嗎
你賺10幾% 你的成本0.2% 你看
這賺你的成本佔那麼少
對不對 你一找一個100塊的股票
然後整天震補0.5%
中華電信
對啊 0.5%
你買要排隊 賣要排隊
買了又不一定排得到賣
對不對 中股票連衝都不能衝
所以呢
我們要選對好的個股跟好的標的啦
所以其實我們今天就先把這個從
盤錢我們要做什麼樣的準備
來選到好的標的來做我們當成的選擇呢
對啊 所以盤錢喔
盤錢你就要想策略啦
你要想說我今天到底要幹嘛
對
要做哪些股票
那設定這個停損點喔
其實停損點我覺得最重要啦
停利還不一定喔
停利這個通常
通常我們是
做多集拉出量停利
放空集殺出量停利
你要記得這個就好
那股票跟股期的正利價差喔
這個有時候你可以看得出來
它的股票的方向比較有機會往哪邊走
那通常假如是正價差就比較有機會往上
大概這樣 這個是機會問題
但是我們不會為了正價差而去
而去做多股票
嗯 那雪股的話呢
雪股我有設計一個這個
當沖標果選手的APP
那雪股裡面事實上是有兩種
一個是資金關注焦點
那另外一個是大量換手高位
那資金關注焦點跟大量換手高位
他們兩個都有一個特色
就是他們都有周轉率在裡面
嗯 那資金關注焦點就是
今天周轉率突然拉高
然後比較偏多的股票
就很多人在進行交易了
對 那大量換手高位呢
是今天這個
周轉率拉高
但有很多隔日沖的股
很多隔日沖分點在裡面
所以呢 我會從大量換手高位裡面
找機會來做空
資金關注焦點裡面
找機會來做多
所以第一個講說這個資金關注焦點
表示很多人在關注這檔股票
所以第一個喔
其實我們這裡面找的周轉率
大概都是全國前20啦
反正你就记得你今天做当初很简单
你就1,700档你都不用看了啦
你就看全国前20周转率排行榜
就好了
资金周转率比较高的
对 你就做这20档
那这20档里面又有分
这20档里面就有分
第一个前天有涨停
有涨停有很多隔日冲
然后现行没有很强
那这个呢 他有可能就大量换手高位
大量换手高位的白话文是什么
就是葛日聰他會拉高出貨
拉高換散戶進來
所以大量換手
高度危險的股票所以比較偏空那假如今天周轉率突然拉上去了然後昨天小紅小黑
那它是今天的資金關注焦點
大概這樣子
了解
我們多空大概會這樣選股
好
所以我們選完之後
接下來開盤了
9點了我們要做什麼事情
盤中你可以看一下
這個是從馬K的資金流向可以看一下
那這個稍微看一下就可以了
因為你實際上關注的標的
標的實際不多啦
就是我們所講的
你就看全國前20
喔
全國前20的周轉率就可以了
所以這是一個概念
就是說這資金可能是流到哪一個
比如比方電子股比較多
或者石化股比較多等等的嘛
沒錯
所以除了這個資金之外呢
我們盤中還是要觀察一下股價的變化
而當中籌碼就是很重要的一個點
對好
那這個潘生資金有了嘛
第二個這個觀察買賣盤捷徑點
比較捷徑點是什麼意思
買賣盤捷徑點
那我們先講一下
我們空股票要空債爆量漲不動
什麼時候會爆量
你去看那個江波土都有啦
股票急拉出很大量
然後你看到那個價格上不去
你要空在那個點
那買債爆量跌不動
急殺出量跌不大下去了
就買在那個點
所以記得這兩個口訣
你就記得這兩個口訣就對了
那股票吉拉呢
它連次連亮會亮紅燈
這裡喔
像這邊呢是亮綠燈
那這個當外盤成交的話
它會亮紅燈
那當燈熄滅的時候
可能會買盤接近
爆量越大會越準
那股票擊殺的時候
像這裡就擊殺
擊殺的時候
連次連亮亮綠燈
等它燈熄滅就準備做多的意思
所以我們就抓緊這兩個口訣
其實我們在我們的盤上面
其實都會看得到
整個資金的動態跟流向了對不對
那除此之外呢
我們帶一些多圖的走勢
也是要必須一起觀察的喔
多圖走勢就是你必須要找到
你今天做的這檔股票
它的同族群的股票漲怎樣
同族群
比方說
像最近比較流行的是BBU
像之前比較流行的是軍工
這軍工類股的走勢
那軍工類股的走勢
你看它走勢就會有點像
嗯
所以就把別忘了漢翔啦
漢翔就跟保益啦
等等就拉出來
然後把同一個產業的個股拉出來
看看它的圖是不是長得一樣
對 看它長得像不像
長得像 所以長得像是什麼意思
長得像喔 長得像你可以記得一點
嗯
ABCDE都長得很像
對 平常旁邊走路都很像
對
那後來呢只有一個在拉
其他都沒在動
那代表這一段拉假的
拉假的是什麼意思
拉假就是這段很有可能再回來
喔
那個就是主力他沒辦法同時發動
發動一支而已
那如果要玩當衝是要玩這種嗎
玩當衝
玩當衝沒有
玩當衝你都要先做好功課
嗯
當衝有分先買再賣先賣再買
先賣再買的
你在前一天你就要想好
你今天要做哪一檔
那先買再賣的
你可以當天再看就可以
當天只要它的周轉率突然變高
那就有機會
所以分成兩種類型喔
對
那接著就是這個盤中還有另外一個觀察
我們剛剛講的捷徑
買盤捷徑是什麼意思
對 你看這邊連刺亮
連刺亮亮紅燈嘛
這就是個這個連亮
連刺也爆了連亮也爆了
然後這邊都亮燈呢
就是等它滅了就是買盤捷徑
那你可以簡單說一下
連刺跟連買
連亮是什麼意思
喔好
連刺喔
這個是我設計的啦
因為盤中的足比出口太快了
一般人看不懂啦
那數太快了 一直刷 一直刷 看不懂
所以呢 我們是把它變慢
那變慢怎麼變慢呢
就是我每五秒算一次
五秒算一次 接這五秒內外盤獲勝 內盤獲勝
總計起來
外盤獲勝一次
像這裡是外盤連續獲勝十次
那外盤的量加一加有兩百多張
那這兩個都報的代表說買盤接近
買完了 大家買完了
對
那另外就是所謂的賣盤結晶
賣盤結晶一樣啊
你看
這是殺下來
我們先看剛剛那個價格
你要記得
因為這同一檔
同一檔
你看這個價格買盤結晶是174.5
然後後面往下殺了
變171
然後這邊變
付的20幾次然後200多
所以呢這個是那個賣盤結晶
所以是一個是買完的
一個是賣完的訊號
我們都要注意了
一個是內盤訊號啦
嗯 了解
所以我們接下來是講一下這一張圖
就是我們剛剛講的這一張
立即49681
這個為例好了
這邊其實就是看到我們剛剛的成交量
跟這個價格
你看喔 這個拉高買盤捷徑我們這邊空
所以你看啊 它極拉買盤捷徑
你看這邊會有粗量
然後這邊會有一個Pick 極轉彎
好 那我
我每天都會在我的IG
IG
欸 先後置一下
我在我的IG呢 我都會貼我的點位圖
就是你發 那個點發生什麼事情
那個點就是 那個點像這綠色就是我今天空的點
這個很多投資人每天都在等這張圖啊
又看我今天做了哪一檔股票
然後他們說 小哥你會不會太省啊
為什麼也是你弄完它 它就轉折下來
我說 不是我太省啊
是因為那個點白 就是買盤結晉點
我只不過是壓倒駱駝的最後一根稻草而已
抓好時間點
我就抓好時間點
快快快就掉下來
就這樣子
好那一樣呢
他殺下來你看
殺下來我們在這邊買
買買之後他可能有個小盤彈
就這樣子
所以你主要的這個概念
其實就是參考那個時候的成交量
跟他的價格嘛對不對
沒錯
了解
所以那這是我們盤中要做的事情了
那接下來一點半收盤之後
你也會做一些檢討嗎
對會
第一個每天要做好交易盤行
那第二個 強勢股多單盡量報警
空單呢 有賺
強勢股的空單有賺就跑
那強勢股建議只短空一次
為什麼
因為強勢股就是很容易後面就敗鋼去
嗯
那若勢股多單有賺就跑
就像強反彈嘛
強反彈有賺就跑
空單要盡量報警
齁
齁 那每天設定好最大虧損的金額
這二跟三其實他概念還蠻接近
就是你不要一次覺得我要賺多少我才走對不對
對啊
就是不要太貪心
可以這樣講嗎
應該這樣講說
你要分辨那盤股票到底是強勢還弱勢
你就看前一天它長什麼樣
看它的籌碼或者看價格
很強的
你又記得你的空單不能擺太久
不要跟市場對坐
對
好
每一設好最大虧損金額
可動用資金的1%
喔
假設你有100萬
可操作金額
你不能說100萬是你的救命錢
不行 那就不要玩了
100萬可多用金額
每天不能輸超過1萬
喔 設定一個
欸 你輸超過1萬
那心情壓力很大耶
對啊 你100萬一天輸10萬
那你怎麼活下去啊
只剩9天可以輸
那100萬輸1萬
那還好 還行一下
還行一下
那務必夠好出價單
避免漲停空單流倉那速度磐石別動作速度磐是什麼意思就是有時候突然急拉我們速度很快那時候先不要動先等一下 先看清楚對 空在股價漲不動
好 急拉回想到均線是個找小賠的好機會
因為有時候 這個我們做空的
就是空了之後 還是往上拉
再回來碰到均線那個點
無論如何 你都要先補掉
嗯
那你不要記得你的成本啦 反正你記得
誰記得成本誰痛苦
不要記得成本 該出就要出
嗯 好
若持續賺錢的話 可以提升最大虧損金額
戶頭持續賺錢可以轉去自殘
自殘 你是說
讓戶頭的潛水流動
喔 這什麼意思
就是要持續的保持資金的
對啊 你們欸
我今天這個每天輸一萬
哎呦 越來越厲害了
可以到每天輸10萬
每天輸100萬 每天輸1000萬
不要越玩越大啦
因為玩越大 它的難度越高
那我問你喔
比方說我現在有100萬的資金
然後我現在想要開始介入當沖這個市場
你覺得我要投入多少比較好
投入多少
嗯
100萬都是你的
反正你要記得
你每天只能輸1萬
喔
那你每天當沖的金額
你有100萬的話
你最好只沖100萬
但一般來講一般你叫他說充100萬他還是覺得太少
太少嗎?我是覺得太多耶
你開始充你之後你就知道100萬
我太報收了
100萬不多
因為花鼠隨便滑一下就100萬了
100塊的你按個1就10萬了
是啦多兩個零
買到台積電了
對啊
那也有人台積電在當充的
真的
我以為這種高價股比較少欸
台積有在當中
而且他都是很厲害的大咖才去沖台積電
他們沖台積電不是為了台積電
OK
他們是為了台積棋
他可以再當沖台積電賠錢
但台積棋他要大賺
他是奮力把台積電往上拉
然後呢
台積電出貨
然後後面呢
他只得把他買了台積電
把它賣下來
當台積電
你看他OS賠錢
可是事實上可能在某個地方一直在賺錢
所以你每次當衝的股票都是電子股比較多嗎
如果都是強勢或流動
我買的我當股票都是波動性大的股票
不一定是電子股
不一定 相信是防疫股
喔
對 波動性大的股票每天不大一樣
反正我每天衝的股票都是周轉域前十名的啦
所以你也不會去了解說這檔
他是做什麼的公司對不對
大概會知道啦
喔喔喔喔喔喔喔喔喔喔
但是不會很詳細的去源
因為那個流動太快了
我們的客人每天都在周轉
最近比較活潑的像BBU
最近比較常來的是BBU
了解 所以我們盤後檢討之外
其實還是要跟各位觀眾朋友講一題
就是今年如果開始要做當成
到底要怎麼樣操作比較好嗎
好 第一個持續觀察市場最近動態
比方說最近防疫
對 最近變得防疫 防疫稍微起來
不過我覺得防疫那個都是一時的而已啦
對
一時而已 那個不會太持久
好
第二個每天要做好重碼研究功課
第三 研究盤面的主流股
那航行發動者最為有利啊
所以一般人沒辦法做啦
航行發動那個都是幾千萬幾億生家人在做的
大戶在做的
所以你真的要跟單速度要很快
那記得集長不要再追了
好 那多广泉股找主投买上回销做多胜率比较大
那空旺选股我们就找高昂出货股
高昂出货股来做
或找一些有隔日冲的
反正重点都是要有隔日冲啦
因为隔日冲他是隔天会卖掉嘛
对
有隔日冲股票那些都是你的
这个跟你会比较
呃算是
算是你的伙伴啦
是 就一起操作啦
对
那你最后讲一下
如果你的当冲心法到底有什么呢
你當衝這麼多年來
好 第一個 維持冷靜
冷靜 心跳大可
對 我要跟自己對話一下
所以跟對話是什麼
跟自己講一下
好 加油 不要慌
只是調整而已
沒有了
好像是大時代
大時代裡面的劇情
好 就維持冷靜啦
不要太恐慌啦
那其實不要恐慌一個很重要的條件
就是你部位不要太大
你部位不大就不會恐慌啦
反正就嚇小一點
好 那自印計畫每天給自己賠錢上線
多單遇到快跌停一率賣出
空單遇到快漲停一率回補
那第三個 警惕風險
不要下超過自己可承受的範圍
那第四個 預設停損單
第五個 保持耐心
大單短進短出
因為風險啦 大單不要放太久
小單要贏到最後 偶爾需要大賺
大賺
大賺大賠 小賺小賠
你記得不要出現大賠
偶爾要大賺
那麼你整體都會賺錢
你通常大賺會賺多少錢
大賺喔
我們 最近比較多的一次400多萬
那大賠 小賠多少
小賠幾萬塊啊
到幾十萬就覺得是大賠了
就覺得賠的有點多
那你平均每天靠當沖可以賺多少錢
平均算不出來
最近12月好了
12月
12月我貼一次兌換單
這個純當沖
純當沖是900多 單月
單月
但是實際上的帳單會比這個醜
因為純當沖
當沖它是一個帳面上會比較漂亮的一個狀況
因為你在虧損的時候
你有可能就不會當沖掉
你就流倉了
你有可能變隔日沖
對 所以我們常常
當沖今天虧比較多
我們會留倉
然後隔天找小培出掉
所以你看到純當沖的帳面會很漂亮
那再把隔天算起來
應該 加退佣應該還是有五六百
五六百
一個月
一個月 對
做得順的話一個月
常常是上百萬
所以今天真的是來跟我們交朋友的
當然
好啦 最後
好
保持健康的生活 早睡早起
有人說他早上沒時間起來
12點起來可不可以學當沖
我說你不要學了啦
你12點
波動都沒了
我真的聽說很多人做當沖
他們一天只睡4個小時
因為我們剛才要盤中盤後
大家都要做很多準備啊 檢討啊
盤前要做一些籌碼啊
他自己想太多吧
不用那麼
除非要做那個夜盤啊
喔 對啦
不然你根本不用這樣子啊
哪要啊
我們晚上12點睡都覺得很晚睡了
真的齁
早上還要起來
那你早上大概8點起來
然後到下午2點就沒事啦
嗯
盤後運動輸壓 也是這種上班
嗯 對
好 第七個不要有太大十年
也沒有一定得怎樣的走勢
嗯
所以今天非常謝謝
我們台灣最大的當充戶之一
來跟我們做一下
这个交流
让我们也很开心
可以今天请到他来分享了
如果你喜欢我们今天的节目
记得帮我们按赞
分享给你的朋友
我们下次见
拜拜